françois bayrou aurait aimé
effectivement que lier une
proportionnelle voci but +25 % oui je
suis aussi de cette famille politique
via sûr qu'on vend comme président mais
je suis de cette famille politique
en même temps comme vous savez il y a
des obligations d'avoir un député par
département il y a des principes
constitutionnels aussi où vous pouvez
pas ya le fameux tunnel des 20% entre
les circonscriptions les plus voilà il
ya des tas de contraintes qui ont fait
que le choix du gouvernement s'est porté
sur ce pourcentage
là encore n'est ce pas c'est un texte
qui va être discutée puisque c'est pas
le premier texte
comme vous le savez la proportionnelle
c'est pas dans le texte constitutionnel
bon c'est un taxi va être discutée et
s'éteint c'est une base de départ n'est
pas sceller dans le marbre les espoirs
de réussite
moi je suis vous venez pas me voulaient
pas me mettre dans un corner je suis
modem nous bien sûr je ne m'en cache pas
je suis solidaire du gouvernement auquel
j'appartiens très bien